is the second base racist if not
why not also why did third base get into
that nascar female driver's panties
oh panties such an interesting word
she's a horrible driver she's terrible
but we have to act as though she's as
good as any man
godaddy.com
when it comes to the emmys there's more
to this than i think people understand
uh
obviously why do we care about the
enemies you know politics is is
culture is upstream from politics so
with the
emmys it also ties into what's going on
with rolling stone espn we'll get to
that in a second
but it might as well have just been i
understand that you're in an industry
people might
lean left but it was proactively a
social justice warrior i don't screed it
was a get-together it was like
it was like alcoholics anonymous for
social justice warriors but it was
broadcast
see this i think the world would be a
better place if more women were in
charge
because unlike the presidency emmys go
to the winner of the popular vote i
thank
trump for making black people number one
on the most oppressed list
we did have a little story line about an
impeachment but we abandoned that
because
we were worried that someone else might
get to it first i suppose i should say
at long last mr president here is your
emmy it came across as mean-spirited
yeah and i know those well tropes mean
it came up for people who love to fan to
themselves as
creative and compassionate not only that
but afterwards if you read the headlines
sean spicer made an appearance and he
poked fun of himself
people were furious like oh i can't
believe anyone would have them out they
were mad at stephen colbert how can you
normalize sean spicer everything from a
knot like this this guy is no longer
he's no longer working for the president
he can't come out and do a joke oh dare
you treat that human like a human can
you believe that that they're actually
mad that they use someone who clearly
has been the butt of a joke for years
and he
for years for months for the last year
and 18 hours and it feels like years and
he just made a joke about himself and
they were furious yeah they hate jokes
and it's awesome you can see a lot about
someone's character by how they act when
they win
something yeah that's a good point yeah
like like you win
and now you're like and now i'm gonna
get back at everybody versus now i'm
gonna be grateful like it's just so
revealing if you were to just throw out
a net like throw out
you know a dolphin catching that into
this audience
and who would you grab how many of them
have been part of
progressive anti-bullying campaigns
right away alec baldwin
kevin spacey stephen colbert you know
they all do those those jump cut
anti-bullying campaigns when you say gay
when you say gay when you say gay
do you know what you say we can take a
stand we can take a stand like that
they've
all taken part in this and then they go
and then they go out here and it's just
it's just attack after attack after
attack
and taunt on president trump and people
can say well it's because they're
punching up
no no listen they are not punching up
they made fun of his reality show
they've made fun of his family these
people have far more power and influence
they certainly did at one point than
some
than just the guy in the white house
this is the cultural entertainment
establishment elite when we talk about
why trump run
won this is a big reason why people tune
into the emmys very few now
on record with the lowest rated emmys
ever and they go i just can't
even people who don't necessarily like
trump are just go it's just a constant
sucker punch and they shut it off alec
baldwin won an award for doing a donald
trump impression which would suck at a
local open mic and he's not even on the
cast at snl it's the only thing he does
okay his trump oppression is just doing
this it's slightly better than ben
shapiro
and then donald glover let's unpack this
thanks
black's the most oppressed group what
what yeah i don't want to watch that i
understand everyone else okay you hate
donald trump but
is it just me it's like completely
nonsensical like i can understand the
leftist making army like okay muslims
the ban
uh you know immigrants because they
don't delineate between illegal and
legal transgenders of the military thing
maybe
yeah no it's it's definitely it's
definitely a little nutty i can't think
of any discernible
none that would harm blacks from donald
trump
uh let even disproportionately
inadvertently harm black people yeah but
let's unpack this by the way black's the
most depressed really
police officers are three times less
likely to shoot unarmed black suspects
you're welcome sincerely white people
three times more likely to be shot
black people don't like that stat it's
absolutely true black people
getting into school in the united states
with lower sat scores thanks to
affirmative action
people screwed the asians they have to
get higher scores they're held to an
absolutely different center black
employment as matter if you want to talk
specifically under donald trump has gone
up
with 700 000 black jobs since he's taken
office so
well you just come out and say black are
the most depressed first off they're not
the most oppressed group in this country
certainly not as it results to systemic
discrimination now if you want to talk
about individual discrimination
ironically of which you're creating more
because you're using your emmy platform
to say that everyone's racist
who helped get you an emmy um yeah
they're individual jackasses
but it has nothing to do with systemic
discrimination is there a that's the
comment of the day
tweet tweet us or comment below what
systemic discrimination is there in the
united states today specifically to
black people making them the most
oppressed group
i want to hear your comments because i
can't think of anything trayvon free who
won
you know an emmy beforehand i guess he
won it he got it in advance i don't know
it's like people who can take their
midterms early
uh so he tweeted out this he tweeted out
standing in the street holding this and
a cab driver looked at me drove past and
picked up a white lady 10 feet behind me
amazing so a couple things with this
tweet people just take it at face value
and it gets you know
millions of people in reach no one hails
a cab in los angeles that woman
calls for that cap she called for that
cat so you're bitching about a cab that
a woman called for uh
every cab driver in los angeles i was
there for you is a middle eastern muslim
am i
am am i wrong here no they're pretty
yeah middle eastern muslims so is this
tweet islamophobic no one going to call
him on that one
why would an emmy matter if he didn't
have one would it be less offensive
would he be more important than a black
person without an emmy
cat middle eastern muslim cab driver
probably saw a dark-skinned guy
with the emmy and thought it was a seek
with a holy dagger looking to take him
out
and by the way just like the rape
accusations none of this holds up
when held with scrutiny no no it doesn't
hold any water
ah i can't we the picture is there was a
cab going by
hey and it went past the black guy to
this white lady
no she calls for a cab and you're a dick
the rolling stone
is up for sale too this relates not only
the emmys but it goes like rolling stone
is up for sale and they
directly admit you can read a quote
where it's because of leftist politics
like people know this it's because
they've continually gone more and more
left and people no longer want to read
rolling stone so subscriber ship is down
who'd have thought that a music magazine
that's become exclusively a political
activist magazine
could possibly go under this is not this
is where again it becomes
mean-spirited when you look at everyone
getting together it's it's like
the cool kids table we all hate trump
right and i get it trump can be a
bombastic ass i'm not saying he's some
shrinking violet i understand it but
when it's
everybody when it's the emmys the oscars
all of the entertainment industry
all of the media complex abc nbc cnn
when it's espn
when it's rolling stone when it's
variety when it's now gq and s when it's
everybody doggy piling on at what point
do you just feel gross for being a
coward
when it comes to the rolling stone if
they learned nothing from espn espn had
to lay off a hundred
on-air personalities because of
subscriber losses like
it was recently jamil hill calling trump
a white supremacist
i mean there are a lot of things you can
say about trump or disagree with but
white supremacist
is not one of them you see it without
again this all ties in these people are
in such an
echo chamber espn doesn't understand
that people
actually tune into them for sports
welcome to sportscenter today in sports
we talk debt ceiling
we also talk washington gridlock are
republicans to blame
most likely of course they are that's
right john also an investigative report
and the increasing and disturbing lack
of diversity in the sport of curling
is such a shame so disturbing 2017 such
a shame
especially when it's so unavoidable john
also men in the women's
locker rooms where sexual assault ends
and transgender rights begin and an
expose on nba's notorious heightism
where the glass ceiling quite literally
is the backboard
where are the shorts alarming or the
asians
later football oh what is that what's
football
it's interesting with emmys ratings are
terrible
rolling stone we're for sale espn
they're hemorrhaging viewers you look at
late night
well first off jimmy fallon is losing to
stephen colbert right now which is
crazy because letterman didn't beat leno
for years remember in the last few years
but they used to get you know six
million eight million a piece by the end
of it it was like
five or six steve is getting three jimmy
fallon's getting two
people are tired of tuning in the more
that these people in entertainment
street get away from their purpose
which is to entertain or to inform on
music or to inform on sports
people shut it off and that's what's
important to note here this is why i
talk about them being bullies because
it's not only a profit motive not that
it would be acceptable
if it were but the left has understood
that culture is upstream from politics
for a long time
but they're willing to take those losses
if they think they can get their digs or
their jabs in
it's not just a profit motive because
you can consistently see across the
board it hurts them
same thing happened with anti-american
movies but they still make redact they
still make
uh rendition lines for limbs espn still
went down this path when they took poll
after poll no one cared about redskins
the emmys is still going on
they ensure that every year is a further
and further left host you look at
rolling stone
you look at vice they just go further
and further to the left and they just
absolutely continue to collapse because
it is an ideological motive they are
trying
to create propaganda it's not working
but they're still going to dig their
heels and and it's important to note
that they're not just going after
dollars they're actually trying to
change your political mind every single
day so when people say hey
why do you talk about the emmys who
cares about the enemies well they care
about the emmys and because culture is
more important than politics
we need to be in the know and it is in
un it's so wonderful
with new media and when you see these
things you know that's with mug club
and youtube that we can actually speak
out against this kind of for as long as
google
and facebook and twitter allow us and
that's why you see
nbc cbs you see espn what are they
trying to do they're trying to
buy influence on youtube they're trying
to buy in they're trying to get in there
where new media started beating them in
the numbers because they're scared
and they're wrong and it's not a profit
motive it's an ideological one
and it's an ideological one that sucks
also
donald glover i i i really i really i
like the guy i think he's funny
but black people most depressed group
are you out of your tree sir
welcome back to sportscenter before we
close out the show it is our duty to
inform you of any of our mistakes
uh this evening and of course apologize
for insensitivity so first i would like
to apologize to the
american fatherless household
association uh for reciting the
african-american statistic which
although entirely accurate was offensive
and out of line i apologize
and i would like to sincerely apologize
for my
remarks uh that i called ping pong quote
unquote
[ __ ] tennis you know we don't get
everything right here at sportscenter
but we always try to correct the record
how was he to know it'd be very
difficult i can understand how
we also apologize that we hired a white
individual to be throwing this
basketball
we should have hired an african-american
for the job
of lobbing us the basketball uh however
it was difficult to find
a negro who would work for 1750 an hour
turns out if they're high level enough
to throw a basketball accurately on air
they should be working professionally
and we sincerely apologize for not
hiring a jewish accountant we are facing
bankruptcy
yes we also sincerely apologize for not
hiring a
non-jewish lawyer which of course we
need to
meet a quota based on consonants in the
last name and
mr silverstein you've also been issued
papers your services are no longer
required we apologize for that as well
very nice man
great great guy but he's taking
someone's spot and i would also
personally like to apologize for calling
the wnba
uh quote unquote a chaotic lesbian party
i would also like to apologize for
saying that the wnba
was quote unquote for those who like
black women but hate good basketball
and i'm very sorry for uh saying that i
wanted
floyd mayweather to hit conor mcgregor
like he was
his wife yeah that one was
not as offensive to accurate not as
offensive to most women
actually because they believed that to
be the case and saw it as a dig
but it was offensive to the overwhelming
number of black males in the community
who when they rarely stay with their
wives
do tend to beat them mercilessly also i
realize that i am being asked to
apologize for uh
insinuating that the biggest asset
danica patrick brought
to the sport of driving was tips yeah
godaddy.com
this is ben sportscenter